because did you play any piano before
rocket man no no and to be honest
i didn't really play that much in rocket
man i i tried you told me you learned
how to play all those songs you sat here
anything after the martini no
i did i did do quite a lot of learning
and prep and i do little bits in the
movie but only little sections but it's
quite intimidating when he walks in
isn't it yeah still maybe we do
something together i was actually just
thinking i feel like you
me and elton should be bffs just the
three of us
and we could you know go on like trips
and i love it i know he's in the middle
of a world tour but i think if we
propose it to him i think he'd sack it
off yeah let's do it
[Music]